by now you may have heard about area
launched in 2012 and backed by Barry
Diller it allows you to watch broadcast
TV over the Internet in 13 cities so far
Aereo has created antenna farms
warehouses full of dime-sized and
tenants these work much like the rabbit
ears you would attach to your television
at home they receive free over-the-air
signals from broadcasters like ABC CBS
NBC and Fox Aereo takes that signal and
resends it to subscribers via the
Internet you can then watch live TV on
your computer tablet and smartphone area
will even let you record shows to the
cloud for later viewing
the service costs eight or twelve
dollars a month but here's where it gets
sticky pre Aereo there were three ways
to watch broadcast television you can
bolt an antenna to your roof or TV and
get it for free you could pay a cable
company for a box or you can pay a
satellite company for a dish while
you're paying cable and satellite
companies they're paying broadcasters so
they can be transmitted their
programming to the tune of about four
billion dollars a year but you know how
much Aereo pays broadcast networks zilch
area argues that it's pulling down the
same free signal anyone can get with
their own antenna the fact that the
antennas happen to be in a warehouse and
not on subscribers rooves they say
shouldn't matter